c'est très important pour les femmes
cinéastes et rouler c'est d'essayer
d'inventer des images et une vision et
de données à partager cette vision qui
soit vraiment féminine féminine elle
était une pionnière du cinéma de la
nouvelle vague dans les années 60 la
mort hier de la cinéaste française agnès
varda à l'âge de 90 ans et un rappel qui
a encore peu de femmes derrière les
caméras mais ce n'est pas le cas sur le
plateau du film québécois merci pour
tout présentement en tournage
une comédie écrite et réalisée par des
femmes mettant en vedette deux actrices
et abdi gély justin boudreault sur le
plateau de tournage du film merci pour
tout impossible de ne pas décrocher pour
les actrices je trouve magali drôle je
me trouve rouge tout je trouve tout
drôle
enfin que mais on arrive quand même à
reprendre un peu de sérieux qu'ils sont
encore au début dans ce film julie
perreault et magalie lépine blondeau qui
joue deux soeurs qui ne se parlent plus
depuis un an c'est la mort de leur père
qui les force à reprendre contact
c'est une comédie entièrement joué
imaginés et réalisés par des femmes
isabelle langlois auteur de lâcher prise
et rumeurs signe mes textes
la réalisation est assurée par louise
archambault qui s'est démarqué entre
autres avec gabriel les personnages
principaux sont aussi féminin mais je
trouve ça l'fun d'avoir ça au cinéma
je suis contente de mettre en valeur
cette complexité la féminine mais c'est
pas au détriment des hommes c'est juste
un complément les femmes sont de plus en
plus présent dans l'industrie du cinéma
en deux ans le nombre de projets signés
par une scénariste ou une réalisatrice
soumis à la sodec est passé de 31 à 51 %
une augmentation attribuable aux mesures
qui encouragent la parité auprès des
producteurs qu à chaque dépôt s'ils
veulent déposer plus qu'un projet il
faut qu'il y ait un des deux qui soit
signé par une femme n'y a pas de quotas
quand un projet de femmes est accepté on
veut que les cinéastes comprennent que
c'est parce que c'est bon elles ont pas
été acceptée parce que c'est un projet
de fin cette initiative dynamise
l'industrie c'est bien que ça existe
cette vérité là pour donner la chance
aux femmes aussi dire allez-y écrivait
des bons films réalisés prenez votre
place et en europe de plus en plus des
projets écrit et réalisé par les femmes
j'espère que ça sera plus inusités
bientôt
mais pour voir merci pour tout il faudra
attendre encore un peu la sortie du film
est prévue à la fin de 2019 ici julie
jasmin boudreau radio canada montréal